ora tutti ragazzi e benvenuti che sono
video sono fa vigenti ed oggi siamo
tornati su bello nei call episodio un
sacco non fatti eravamo rimasti che
avevo trovato la m mi sta dentro la casa
del tizio e adesso vi faccio vedere che
cosa c'è dopo la metro nella casa del
tizio buona fermati un secondo
vai vai parte nessuno ce l'ho fatta sono
e la metro o atto dove cazzo stiamo
andando raga no fermi sarò bellissima ma
quante psicopatico sto tizio la vera gas
ci sono le scatole impilate che farò
fuori subito però terminare questo
ascensore qua in teoria dovrebbe portare
fino al piano di sotto cosa che vedremo
dopo perché adesso dovete devo capire
cosa c'è dietro le scatole papam nello
tirate giù cosa mi che è sta roba
fermi tutti i ragazzini tutti
quart devo mettermi a fare parkour zio
team nokia ragazzi alla devo arrivare
all'ultimo piano siamo quasi arrivati
tra l'altro non so che cosa c'è nelle
altre stanze che devo aprire con le
chiavi visto che sono arrivato fino a
qua però va bene ok perfetto prova a
vedere se riesco a saltarci dentro però
non so come arci qualcosa lì come faccio
la sedia o sradicato sedie nel frattempo
va bè perfetto maometto una roba
impilata
[Musica]
non imitate quello che sto facendo a
casa ragazzi c'è nella casa dei vicini
non limitate a casa vostra potete anche
farlo dai il porca vacca e dai ma per un
nulla
un anno e mezzo per questa chiacchierata
un anno siamo arrivati a questo punto
dove canzonato alla mia chiave
[Musica]
maghetta ma che credo che cazzo è
successo c'è un magnete che attira gli
oggetti di metallo attaccati al muro e
perché a me servono quelle chiavi devo
vedere cosa c'è dietro le porte
[Musica]
che cosa mi piace ragazzi siamo
all'ultimo piano della casa del vicino
c'è questa cosa
e c'è una chiave verde che non posso
prendere finché non disattivo il magni
questo ma niente a dire le cose come
cazzo lo disattivo io magnete a proprio
così però si attacca tutto datevi
qualcosa di non magnete una scatola la
scatola nera magnetica è la madonna come
faccio a disattivare sta merda le chiavi
che sono attaccati al muro a me servono
e servono le chiavi che come si
disattiva sto schifo
spero vivamente che la soluzione non sia
rivede altre porte con le chiavi perché
le chiavi sono state risucchiate dal
muro d'acqua vedo se attivo meno allora
facciamo così l'obiettivo e disattivare
la macchina che non ho idea di come si
disattivi per adesso va bene così porca
vacca che figata a non andare all'ultimo
piano dove ragazze la facciamo così
disattiviamo quello schifo andrò a
vedere se riusciamo a tornare giù in
teoria c'è questa scala spero funzioni
che cazzo cieli sopra
secondo me la scala non funziona però va
bene ora la la m che storia e va bene
allora niente
sì però magari non sfrecciate davanti
casa come se niente forse sono
abitazioni qua non si esca disattivare
l'elettricità giu e quindi in teoria ora
cav h no no no no no no no neurologia
non lo zio ti prego di provvedere a me
ma mi aveva visto sì mi aveva visto che
ha fatto tutto in predicato sto tizio
possiamo è diventato scemo reagan
niente di sopra di sopra allora
aspettiamo che arrivi la roba perfetto
che va ai partiti proviamo a vedere se
non lo so se sei disattivato io ho
staccato la corrente di casa poi brutti
come no perché sento il rumore lo sento
ancora io li mortacci sua non sei
disattivato un pene come faccio a
disattivarlo regala io vorrei salire se
poi possibile risalire sopra posso un
anno e mezzo per questa roba
questa sera qua sopra c'è tutto sto
bordello e poi non c'era niente mi
prendi per il culo ma che ci posso
entrare da dentro
l'umilta midollo con l'ombrello con
l'ombrello no no no non l'ho sbagliato e
va beh sì grazie
due sono a sono arrivato di somma faccio
prima a piedi ma che storia
ok va bene non ho capito ma va bene cosa
stavo stavo sbaglio stavo riuscendo a
sbagliare non vorrei dire ma stavo
riuscendo a sbagliare aprista porta per
favore dove mi porta a sti posti ci sono
un sacco di nome nascosto in un altro
ombrello ma basta tanti ombrelli ci sono
perché davis alternante dall'altro
questo questo è chiusa ci mancava guarda
è perché c'è una luna dietro simbolo
qual è il problema e sostanza è questa
perché tutto misterioso deve essere qual
è il che giurò che si fa al tipo allora
ragazzo li vediamo se è ok perfetto va
guarda guarda semi semi vestina travolta
ti smontato pezzo per pezzo
ragazzi miei in tutto questo sto girando
tutto il posto praticamente dai dai che
ci arrivi ma non è vero
e vabbè allora tutti ci sono ciao zio
come ci ho trovato ragazzi ci ho provato
in tutti i modi ci dovremo provare ci
dovevo assolutamente provare fatemi
entrare da qualche parte ce l'ho fatta
sono per lo so neanch'io raga ma sti
cazzi sono ca l'importante è non cadere
giù va bene così dove cazzo se c'è un
telecomando funziona
questo gioco sta diventando decisamente
sempre più strano per ragazzi questo
però c'è tutto sullo nei borghi che roba
che devo fare in realtà e spegnere la
macchina che non non ho idea di come si
spenga però tanto c'è una la verifica
c'è una stanza dietro il mulino gigante
spero di trovare un modo per riuscire a
farcela magari lasciatemi dei consigli
nei commenti magari proverò le possiamo
pisodio è stato che si fa quello
comunque il tipo problemi mentale dove
dovete avuto dei problemi seri per lei
ragazzino ha steso io mi sento come se
mi piace anche ai social come riportata
nell'edizione sono se questi si scateni
ci vediamo cos'è la vita dei ragazzi
[Musica]